the bill of rights as we know it today
were the first 10 amendments
to the constitution
and these amendments guaranteed
individual liberty to make sure that
citizens had a stated expectation for
what the government could or could not
do to them and you can kind of see
here in many of these rights the legacy
of the revolutionary war and the kinds
of government abuses that citizens in
the colonies had feared i'm going to go
over these very quickly we'll spend a
lot more time in other videos talking
more about these amendments but i want
to give you an overall sense of
what they're driving at now the first
four amendments guarantee individual
liberties
these are freedom of religion speech
press assembly freedom to ask the
government for redress of grievances or
to deal with a problem that the
government may have caused in your life
the right to bear arms and assemble
militias state and local militias had
made the revolutionary war a success for
the united states a ban on quartering
soldiers in homes recall that the
quartering act when the british
government said that the colonies had to
put up soldiers in their homes was a
major driver of revolution and a ban on
unreasonable search and seizure that is
it would be necessary for the government
to get a warrant to enter your home or
to search your belongings the next four
amendments in the bill of rights
deal with protections for
people accused of crimes
and again you see the legacy of the
revolutionary war in the idea that
the crown had had too much power to
persecute individuals so
this includes things like the right to
due process that is to make sure that
all the steps of following the law are
taken a ban on being tried twice for the
same crime
rights to a speedy and public trial a
jury of your peers to even have a jury
in cases that don't have to do with
violent crimes but rather civil disputes
and a ban on excessive bail and cruel
and unusual punishment basically this is
a guarantee that the government will
respect the rights of individuals now
one of the arguments made against
including a bill of rights in the
constitution was that listing out those
rights might then mean that they were
the only rights and that by listing out
these rights in particular they might be
forfeiting their liberties in other ways
so the ninth and tenth amendments
attempt to deal with that worry they say
in the ninth amendment any right that
isn't listed here
is still retained by the people so this
this is not an exhaustive list this is
not the complete list of all the rights
retained by the people and the tenth
amendment is slightly different but kind
of on the same line they say that if
this constitution has not delegated a
right directly to the federal government
then that right is reserved to the
states or the people so the federal
government can only do the things that
are listed in this constitution
it is a limited government limited by
this document
on the other hand the rights of the
people are unlimited so if the
constitution doesn't say that the
federal government can do it that's then
a right of the states or the people